congress is shut down people have you
heard about that that's right with their
whopping 10
approval rating which it's like as high
as it's been in years uh they decided to
walk out this is the house gop decided
to shut down the government mostly the
tea party faction because they're not
happy with obamacare but don't take my
word for it let's find out a little
information about the shutdown okay so a
real simple explanation of the shutdown
and what it means basically every year
the government has to pass a budget by a
certain deadline to continue existing
this deadline was midnight on monday
this year some republicans basically the
tea party wing in the house refused to
pass a budget unless we get rid of or
delay obamacare which obviously obama
has backed in the supreme court has said
is legal obama and the democrats say
they won't be held hostage by
republicans trying to get what they want
since everyone including congress and
the supreme court already upheld
obamacare that's what i just said and
the government will come back when they
pass a budget okay so we are in day two
of this the world war ii memorial was
blocked off the uh there's this thing at
the nih where kids with cancer aren't
getting trials i mean this is just
absolutely absurd as we tape this right
this second it just broke that obama is
going to meet with boehner and harry
reid today so maybe something will
happen
but president obama had this to say at
the white house yesterday republicans in
the house of representatives refused to
fund the government
unless we defunded or dismantled the
affordable care act
they've shut down the government over an
ideological crusade to deny affordable
health insurance to millions of
americans
in other words they demanded ransom just
for doing their job okay so there you
have it uh president obama is being very
clear this is a law that was already
passed and now they're trying to stop
the government because they don't like
the law which everybody knew
is this is a hundred percent blame here
on this tea party faction of uh the gop
i'm gonna put it at their ga they get
the two percent senator ted cruz gets
another 98.
yeah this is where it originated i mean
of course the the um the different
resolution at least their different
budget came up through the house ted
cruz is a senator you wonder why i'm
connecting the two he basically and this
has been said today too he basically
told them i need you guys to send up
this stupid bill that that defunds
obamacare or at least delays it for
another year and then included with i
have a great idea
with our budget so that we could not
either be forced to go along what we
need to do now he was getting pushback
from that before it finally happened but
we had people like representative peter
king and he came and said this guy is
crazy but you know what we're going to
give him what he wants and watch him
just flounder and watch him fall apart
in front of all of us peter king a guy
who i'm pretty sure you wouldn't agree
with on 90 of the stuff but you're
giving him some credit exactly now with
his thing now i've also said a few weeks
ago he's he's already mentioned a little
bit he wants to run for president which
is insane to me but and then so the if
you re if you read you know
i guess the writing on the wall so does
senator cruz so i think he's already
going after cruz to be like this guy's
gonna have way more support than i will
more money so he makes sure i get ahead
of this and disparage him right now i
think that's his motivation yeah which
is fine because they're gonna fight
later but he actually comes on the right
side of this because there is no real
end game
hey reid said this is dead when he gets
the senate obama said come on you think
i'm gonna sign this so it's it's never
gonna work that way
so it was all just
a stunt really to get more attention on
senator cruz now the house went along
with it and
partially for this reason and i think
others went along there because they
kind of have to because they're
republicans and they'll have any any
real thoughts for themselves so now the
support is now building behind what
crews started and it looks like the
entire party has started and it's
damaging them all right okay so jr's
giving us a nuts and bolts here but what
do you think about the broader point of
everyone having to stick with party all
the time and being held hostage by this
little group of people and all that i'll
use some media reference analogies i
liken this scenario to
uh arlen rickman robbing the nakatomi
building
claiming
that this is very political when they
were just robbing they just wanted money
they were just robbing the building and
pretending it was political and that's
from his perspective that's what he's
doing now let's go over to what is obama
doing
i think this is obama's breaking bad
closing episode where he doesn't mind
how much damage this does his image as
long as he knows he completely took the
other side out in the process ah i like
these references
on them you know yeah that was our first
die hard reference ever on the show i
like that oh there you go very nice
they are playing a fake indignation
thing where clearly if you examine their
behavior they don't actually care about
any of the things that's the whole point
of being fake royalty or whatever you
think royalty's new name is for the 21st
century so you can live on this land and
be it you know oligarchy whatever you
want to call it i think oh my god the
whole point of oligarchy is i get to
tell you not to do something and then
when i close my door i get to do it
exactly so what's the whole point of
being me yeah so speaking of the fake
indignation because that's what this now
seems to be about now that we're we're
you know into day two of this this idea
of the world war ii memorial being
closed and the veterans can't get in
there and you know that the republicans
are now saying well we'll not even get
paid because everyone's just playing
these little games how do we get this
thing how do we get the discussion out
of the nonsensical games because if you
watch cable news it's just endless
bickering back and forth and and you
mean forward to get back to the actual
nuts and bolts yeah people actually see
and hear that yeah
i don't know because that's what this is
as i said as i was trying to rush
through all of it and there were still
five more things i was thinking i was
like this is beginning to get boring i
should stop yeah that was that was just
the internal voice in my head was going
i should stop with this spattering of
everything that's going on because no
one wants to hear that and so that's
going to be the general conventional
wisdom
the assignment is regardless of what
you're faced with you try and get it out
anyway and regardless of how the initial
reaction to a something that is like
waking up in the tub of goo in the
matrix with the wire shooting at your
head and you realize what your real
existence is that's kind of shocking a
lot of people don't want to admit that
right off the bat because what does it
make you do it makes you you're so
decades long wrong you've been wrong for
decades who wants to own that
who wants to say i've been born wrong
right right right
that way of course well this very
convenient way to lock that out even
though there may be a whisper trying to
remind you of it when you're shaving in
the morning
you know and there's ways to go into
denial but i think that other voice when
enough data is faced the other way that
voice inside gets louder and louder you
can't ignore me anymore man it's on
every channel you flip to yeah now you
gotta look so playing devil's advocate
for a second going with what you're
saying if the republicans if this group
really believes that this law is going
to bankrupt the country if they really
believe what they're saying you know
this is going to bankrupt the country
that this is an overreach of government
and it's unconstitutional even though
the supreme court said it is then
shouldn't we maybe give them a little
credit for standing up for what they
believe in i'm totally playing devil's
advocate because it's obviously not what
i believe but if that's what they
believe do they deserve any credit for
that
no i mean because okay it's good
i mean if you go into it you have to
follow you you're you you're a product
of the environment you you're a
politician you know how this whole thing
works there's plenty of things that we
don't like i think president obama came
up with this analogy he said you know we
want background checks for for guns
we've been fighting for it we still
haven't gotten it cause there's still a
lot of americans who are hell-bent on
shooting each other for no reason and
actually people who don't need to have
their these guns in their hands to
continuous to other people now he said
should i because this isn't what i want
for our in our government and our laws
now hold up things that are actually
responsible and are
are necessary for us to do to get this
other part of the law that i want
because there's a segment of population
that is dying for it or not dying
foreign
cancer patients now can't get in yeah
they're not letting them in anymore they
lock the door and there's a certain kind
of dexter missing chromosome kind of
human that's okay with that yeah and
there's a bunch of them yeah but uh and
the one thing the last thing they want
is that part exposed oops yeah that
part's out now so i think the walls are
closing in on that kind of person
because it was a party set up for a kind
of person
the kind of person that knows whatever
kind of mean crap is going on inside me
i don't have to change a thing i got a
welcoming carpet for the one places
you're the guy we're looking for do you
think that's just like you think that's
based on understanding of what's going
on or do you think it's because we're
pulling on heartstrings because that's
all politics is that right which is why
we had stuff like the national zoo
tweeted oh well we can't have the panda
cam people are freaking out about the
pandas
these kids can't get cancer treatment
literally and the panda cam holy cow
that's leading the news all right so
final thought on this uh
this is proof to me more than anything
else that i hate to be that guy but we
need a third party in this country we
need somebody between uh you know these
nut jobs on the right and then they keep
dragging the left more to the center i
mean it just seems crazy but is there
any chance is there any chance for it
remember where the compass is remember
where the compass needle ought to go
because that gets moved wherever someone
with the most amount of power could put
the middle way over to the right you've
got this little sliver left on the end
of the bathroom counter she took it over
with makeup you know that's the middle
yeah and uh
the the remembering it's about others
and so they're trying to get into
everyone's head forget about others
you're on your own and that kind of
thinking i think is up for review across
the board because they made a mistake
they started screwing a lot of them too
and they're waking up that was like they
didn't do everything in the right order
right and and their own believers are
really in deep denial but they're
starting to question once you take my
supplies away and they're taking their
supplies away too doesn't have to change
the makeup of americans for us to do
that though because americans are we're
so competitive we're of course our first
thing you always hear is we're number
one we're the best this we're the most
exceptional all these things so then
that's to our macro but then within our
own country we have our sports teams we
have our collegiate teams we have our
schools we went to just for pride
themselves so now everything we have
those factions were broken down so
everything is a competition
so how many people enough to garner this
third party are going to default from
the republican party do you fault from
the democratic party and say i'm no
longer with those loyal the teams i've
been loyal to for my entire life my
grandfather's democrat all that stuff
how do we do that on a large enough
scale that's the hardest question well i
think that's a perfect uh finish on that
and to that point you know for all these
people on the right that think america
is so great and america it can be a
great country well then maybe uh giving
health care to everybody will actually
work if we're as great as we keep saying
we are okay so cnn which used to be the
most trusted name is news and now is
just something that's sort of between
fox news and msnbc i'm not really sure
anymore they have brought back crossfire
which is the worst of the partisan hack
fest that we deal with endlessly in this
country you've got your two guys on the
left and your two guys on the right and
they give you talking points and they
yell at each other and they bring on
guessing you know what everyone's
thinking already and they stick to party
line okay that's fine
but now it's gotten even worse because
uh newt gingrich who's one of their
hosts on the right obviously he no
longer has to disclose when he's raising
money for the very people that he's
interviewing so let's first look at a
statement by cnn's evp of standards and
practices rick davis this is their
original statement uh before the show
launched if newt is helping fund a
candidate and that candidate's on the
show or being discussed on the show of
course he'll disclose that disclosure is
important when it's relevant okay i
think we can all agree with that that
when the host of a show is raising money
for someone he's interviewing people
should know about that maybe a little
something on the bottom maybe a little
something to the camera
but uh no they've actually changed their
policy over at cnn and he no longer has
to let's take a look at the new policy
we are clarifying the policy and making
it clear newt gingrich is not in
violation the policy if a crossfire
co-host has made a financial
contribution to a politician who appears
on the program or is the focus of the
program disclosure is not required
during the show since the co-host's
political support is obvious by his or
her point of view expressing the program
this is beyond beyond bonkers ridiculous
because he is the host of a show and
occasionally republicans don't always
agree republicans or democrats don't
always agree with democrats but they're
basically telling you this show is so
biased that we we are just throwing all
journalistic practices out the window uh
i know for a fact here at tyt we would
never do that jank would never let me do
it he would never do it himself jr i'll
start with you on this one because you
are a ty tier
isn't this exactly why we need
independent news and online news and
everything and as basis as basic as it
is there's been times when junk was
interviewing someone and he'd say you
know i'm gonna say right now i'm in
favor of your candidacy i'm aware of
your campaign so let's put that on there
out in the first place and i'm sure you
didn't give me any money because we
don't have any money to give to any of
these guys so or or the raising of money
the most money-raising thing we have or
fundraising we do is for wolf pack which
has been repeated over and over again
through the whole situation but um so
when it comes to this this is just
protecting their
we have newt gingrich we we can't lose
his perspective because that's awesome
uh yeah so we have to keep his
perspective on the show so we're willing
to change everything we do because they
feel they're being left behind this all
goes back to the
to the battle they need to get the
ratings up or to get ahead as we were
talking about before it's the reason why
the discourse in america is so low
because all we can think is team
democrat team republican and when you
have a show that completely exhibits it
every day it's like a basketball game
every day between
team democrat and republican
thinking well we have one of those one
of the superstars we have to keep him we
want to change everything for that
because if we don't
they feel they're going to fall apart so
so is the problem here that because
because this is a daily show and it's
inside the beltway and one of the hosts
is a former presidential candidate who's
been around forever they'd have to put
that little disclosure up constantly
right wouldn't that disclosure if they
were really going to show you who he's
linked to and who they're all linked to
that disclosure would never go away yeah
it would be like pop-up video
right
yeah
just to totally date myself no that was
that's the thing with crossfire uh
oh weepy reminiscent
uh everybody loves pop-up video
yeah the thing with crossfire is that uh
you know who gets hurt in crossfire it's
always the innocent stuck in between and
then
they're they're a lot of bravado a lot
of shouting to make it interesting when
there's no reason to shout for this
portion of the topic yeah just trying to
keep the old farts awake in their easy
chairs
wake up pops we're talking about some
what what yeah right and and uh it's
become all
it's a substance-less fluff now it seems
like barking for barking's sake yeah and
though they'll cover a topic they got
that cnn standard well that's all we can
do right now well we'll have to leave it
there the wolf blitzer bailout you're
right
yeah uh there and when you just look at
their sponsors
and you just see who runs the whole
operation how how could they yeah so
could they possibly not be abridged at
this point yeah so whose fault is this
though is it is it this
television network is is this cnn's
fault because they're really
backtracking on pretty basic
journalistic standards that you have to
it's really low fruit or is this really
the fault of the the political machine
because everybody is connected or is it
a combo or is it or am i missing
something all together i i want to put
all of it on cnn because i mean you
already had your general practices you
had your your guidelines for what you
would normally follow and i mean at
least i put out there i know how hard
you had to scour to get this information
about the change politico got it yeah
and it wasn't that hard so they put it
out there and basically thinking well
we've uh we've we've run the gamut of
all of our bs that we throw at americans
so if we change our policies and say
we're not going to keep telling you how
we're breaking the rules that we set up
in the first place they're going to
forget about noah because they really
don't care because all they care about
is seeing more people yell at each other
yeah we need we need that rather than
real practices yeah so then is the other
problem here that these guys they're all
friends too you know what i mean it's
not just about money but everyone you
see on cnn constantly they're playing
golf together they're doing the white
house correspondent they all want to be
invited to the same parties and and go
to the same dinners and they put a
puppet show on for the kids yeah
pretending they're on opposite sides
basically you know yeah you know
is that why the camera's so close to all
their heads in crossfire also because it
actually looks like puppets it's just
two floating heads with that black
background it's like team america yeah
the picture in my head of like well now
i'm dating myself when i call it i still
call it the wwf i still do oh yeah i'm
fine with that yeah right so
when you know when when the bad guy
comes out interviews with gene oakland
yeah and he goes i'm gonna kick your ass
just wait till i get out there and then
you know off screen they're the best of
friends there's been guys that said the
bad guys of wrestling are the nicest
guys and a lot of times the good guys
are wrestling are actually in
real life
and really
the bad guys are the nicest ones you'll
meet in person so they're out there to
do the things so they can't you know
there's a show they can't do it and
disclose well you know triple h
actually doesn't dislike the rock
they're actually they just had dinner
last night they have
their
i'll date myself and let you all know
that i learned my entire political
philosophy from jake the snake robbery
ted cruz he is sort of started this
whole
government shutdown thing because he
hates obamacare did his 21-hour
filibuster that actually wasn't a
filibuster sort of because it was
against a republican house bill and he's
a republican in the senate okay blah
blah blah did you know he is backed by a
pot-smoking
gay billionaire yeah that's right uh
peter thiel who is the
founder of paypal he was also one of the
first investors in facebook he has given
a ton of money to
ted cruz uh actually i have a number
here
he gave two million dollars to the club
for growth which is not a hair club i
thought it was on first look that's a
super pac that then gave over six
hundred thousand dollars to ted cruz's
election campaign in texas uh now some
of the other things that peter thiel has
given money to include space travel life
extension anti-aging artificial
intelligence uh and he even gave a
hundred thousand dollars to 20 kids not
to go to college just to see what would
happen with their lives so he's into
some pretty progressive scientific
things which all seem very reverse of
what ted cruz believes um
what do we make of this and how much can
we get out of that someone gives someone
money can we really glean everything
into them uh can you figure really
figured out about them yeah i mean this
one's a little bit of an easy bouncing
ball to follow here peter thiel is a
staunch libertarian he's all about you
know the extreme measures of people
being able to do whatever they want as
long as everything is privatized now ted
cruz has to appeal to his more
conservative constituents however he
also is a kind of you know very strict
constitutionalist according to what ted
cruz is saying right now at least he's
coming out swinging like constitution
constitution it's one of his favorite
words well that's in line with what
peter thiel is in line with so even
though you wouldn't think that um maybe
on a social scene that they would match
up at least for what peter thiel's
immediate goals are for his finances and
where he wants his super back to go and
the club for growth is heavy heavy
libertarian stuff he sees that ted cruz
is kind of the person who's an
up-and-coming loudmouth um type of
person that would champion him now it's
interesting is ted cruz has kind of been
distancing himself from peter thiel in
certain circles you know going oh gosh
well you know the gayness and the pot
smoking and basically all these things
that are central to probably things in
his daily life and that makes up who he
am has nothing to do with all this money
and the fact that he loves the private
sector he loves the constitution too
right what kind what could ted cruz hate
more than gayness and pot smoking can
you even think of i guess obamacare not
liking the constitution apparently it
would be interesting and it would be a
real opportunity for ted cruz which
unfortunately i doubt he's i don't think
he'll take it but if ted cruz really
wanted to come out and be a leader in
his party what he would say is look this
person's values are in line with mine he
is gay he you know smokes marijuana but
his values are in line with mine that he
wants less government that he wants less
people up in our business or whatever
you know the tea party's obsessed with
and actually turn the party around and
say we can have people that don't look
like us sound like us you know and have
the same social values on our side and
he could turn the whole party right
right so rick before i let you jump in
so these other things like space travel
that is something that ted cruz is not
big on funding i assure you i actually
can't swear to a fact but life extension
anti-aging artificial intelligence i
mean these are all the type of things
that get cut from budgets because
they're based in science teal's just
putting the hip and hypocrisy
yeah that's all he wants because you
know he's hoping no one puts this level
of analysis into the issue and hope that
whatever they hear about the story
they'll assume it's a lie
and uh they'll go right back to whatever
their world looked like right before
they heard this news there's ways to
lock truth out they've figured out how
to do it yeah so i think they're doing
it on purpose though i think that this
is in line with what peter thiel wants
peter thiel is a strict
constitutionalist and libertarian so he
believes that he should be with his
private money money funding space travel
funding all these things so ted cruz
again would get on board with him by
saying the government shouldn't be
funding all these experiments and all
these unnecessary things this should
come from the private sector so you
could profit on it once you know they
are very much in line this relationship
makes a lot of sense yeah again if they
could just come around and say we don't
care if you're getting you smoke weed
you have all the same values as us yeah
so in a weird way so they're they're
sort of like an unholy alliance but in a
bizarre way it's sort of based in things
that they seem to believe so is actually
is something like this okay can for
example just going with the gay thing is
it okay for someone who is gay who i
assume believes in equality to go ahead
and back someone who doesn't believe in
that or is that an overriding issue
related to all the others i think our
standards for okay and theirs are two
entirely different planets yeah what we
call okay it's not even on their radar
you know and what they call okay there's
just different things that they want and
the shields they'll put up and a lot of
these things are just you know a lot but
claiming to be christian is often just a
safe house for a creepy dude there goes
now you've got to go through that nine
miles of concrete i just put between us
yeah and i'm just i'm safer here longer
is all it is you know and i think a lot
of what they're saying into the camera
is it would we have a it seems like the
the mainstream news has a tendency to
ask a liar if they're a liar
which is the definition of insanity you
know i don't think i don't think they
mean
most of what they say yeah on the air i
think they just want us the their
followers to believe they mean it they
want their followers to be antithetical
to them in many ways as long as it
serves them on the yard that's a dog you
want outside but not in the house yeah
so so what's the deal with uh
libertarians and the gay issue because
to me a true libertarian who believes in
liberty and limited government and that
you should believe in what you believe
and own your body and your mind should
they should be rand paul and ted cruz by
the definition of what they're supposed
to believe in should believe in in
marriage equality
and that and that doesn't mean anything
forget the memo that morning i gotta
mean this today yeah i think that they
are in this world so i covered the lnc i
covered the libertarian national
convention and there were more
very open transvestites transsexuals
people i mean with extreme you know
different social things that they were
into there at the lnc because they
wanted to be part of it and they were
excited about last year's candidate was
governor gary johnson from new mexico
i've interviewed him he's extremely
socially liberal but extremely fiscally
conservative which i think is weirdly in
line again with what the tea party wants
and the tea party is just this weird
super right faction of kooks that's
they're so right wing that they forget
that what they really want can only be
accomplished by privatizing and leaving
people the f alone so when they forget
that leaving you alone is really what
they want your that means your bedroom
too not just your finances not just your
health care not whatever they think they
want not touched by the government that
means the government leaves nothing
alone no marriage amendments blocking
marriage that means people can do what
they want right but libertarians cherry
picking so how do they do how do they
cherry pick that that's what i'm trying
to figure out here how do they decide
that they gay so that's purely why it
shifts from week to week as they get a
new memo oh no this group's mad they're
like the guy on the sullivan show bad at
that that is spinning this place but now
these guys are mad over here over here
but now this one is wobbling i gotta run
back there that's why they all are drunk
they all look like they're falling apart
they're doing this fedo room to room run
around farce trying to hold a lie
together yeah and and the one thing they
didn't want was the internet starting to
get the truth out and it was starting to
show tv shows that would have the truth
and people publishing the truth and it's
disintegrating their little bubble that
was there wasn't supposed to be that
other data out there it was only
supposed to be our version of the bs out
there that's falling but we're watching
that part fall apart this is like the
martian walkers and war of the worlds
and they look like they're going to
fight but now there's liquids spilling
out they're weak and they're falling all
over the place now you could knock them
over they're disintegrated by their own
basically that's it yeah all
right well there are no spinning plates
here i promise you because i don't know
how to do it okay let's uh let's stick
with pot because an interesting study
came out with pot pot is hot these days
uh the boston medical center and the
boston university school of medicine
have found according to this new study
that marijuana has no negative effects
on human health
that's right let's take a look at some
of the study
they found that no differences between
daily marijuana users and those using no
marijuana in their use of the emergency
room hospitalizations medical diagnoses
or their health status our findings
suggest that the marijuana use has
little measurable effect on
self-reported health or health care
utilization in adults using drugs
identified in a primary care clinic so
this is obviously linking health
directly to marijuana use and they're
not seeing any discrepancies
i'm going to guess that this doesn't
surprise any of the three of us rick i
start with you uh once again i think
they read their mail
just like dr sanjay gupta suddenly read
his mail and said dude you want to stay
on the air
you got a lot of people who are furious
with you you gotta give that up so
pretend it's a giant epiphany and change
in your position on air you're up and
five write something good and go yeah
and i think essentially he probably knew
but he knew a long time ago but his
pharmaceutical backers which might mean
they are coming
uh
closer to their own cannibinoid
pharma version of everything that'll
work this time the one says okay tell
sanjay he can ease up a little bit yeah
well that's an interesting
because in the quote it kind of tells
you that right yeah but that's a really
interesting theory i think that you
think that they're somehow going to
figure out the the pharma
pharmacological version and then
one of the bloom industries that's
saving california and saving washington
and saving uh colorado there the the
economies are boosting up like crazy
from it
someone who had the previous power base
is going to pay a ton of attention to
that and have huge long death oak desk
meetings about what they're going to do
to have their piece of that yeah like
the way uh cigarette companies are
figuring out now what packaging will
look like yeah and this isn't just the
business model it is that means an
inevitability when they have the new
munchy meal from you know burger king
right much of everyone's prepping and
ramping for it so you'll get you'll get
the weed next door to burger king and
then you'll go in for the munchies at
burger king um yeah so obviously this
this doesn't surprise us but do you do i
mean what what is it about everybody
that takes them so long so sanjay gupta
is a good example because and i and i
know your answer already but he was one
of these people that was completely
against it then he had this huge maya
culpa a couple weeks ago everything i
knew was wrong but yeah i'm not a doctor
i knew that it was okay so we all have
for a very long time i think there's two
factors going in here i think you're
absolutely right i think that even in
that statement that you just read you
could see that the language they're
using is starting to move towards it has
no impact on people seeking treatment it
has no impact on the weight of the
health care system is what they're
essentially saying they're saying
emergency rooms and people coming in for
treatment are no sicker are needing no
more care no more financing from the
government or anybody um and i think
they're also paving the way for it to be
legal so they could get money from it
and all they need to do is flip the
switch and certain people who need the
authorities to tell you so right now we
have lots of older baby boomers we have
lots of conservatives other people that
like authoritarian like it or not some
people like authoritarian things to be
told to them before making their
decisions some people were just more
comfortable that way they're not
comfortable getting their information
from the internet or common sense they
like to be told abc equals this you know
so i think that once the government and
wants more studies funded by
universities and once people like
authorities like dr sanjay gupta who's
now at authority apparently on cnn great
but that's going to mean that people are
more comfortable now with it so we all
knew this i think people that are
forward thinking know this but it's just
that last you know there's like the
early adopters and there's that last
wave they need to be told it's okay and
now they're like it's called we have the
early adopters that sounds good what are
the people who you have to drag at the
end
the dumb deaf and blind i don't know the
dumb deaf no offense to the blind people
and deaf people that are at home going i
knew that and you know come on right so
just playing the devil's advocate here
as i have to do occasionally is there
any risk in this that if you if you make
all this stuff or if you make we illegal
that then kids will be trying it younger
and when their brains are forming and
you know the cognitive parts of their
brain and they're putting in weed that
often now is much stronger than it used
to be and all that kind of stuff is
there to the alcohol model
between the 20s and now is that
is maybe there's a prohibition to uh
canceling prohibition model you can look
at for that and they could check the
stats on that it's an interesting good
question i don't know what the numbers
would be for that yeah but everybody so
if you're if you're a kid and you want
to drink when you're in junior high or
high school you're probably going to
have a few drinks the same way if you
were going to smoke pot you were going
to smoke pot i think you are correct by
saying it's like prohibition i don't
think saying that it's legal for medical
purposes is going to entice a kid like
oh for medical purposes this is cool
it's cooler for me to smoke now i think
it maybe it'll make it a little less
cool that it's a kind of a medicinal
thing rather than you know like a
naughty thing or just to get messed up
right and the second you can get it at
the starbucks of weed it won't be cool
anymore so final thought on this um
2016 is there a chance that one of the
candidates that a real sort of
mainstream candidate is going to get on
board at least legalizing it at the
state level i could see maybe
somebody doing that is that is that
totally crazy rights candidate possibly
who will defer to that but will not come
out in support of it
okay so somebody probably a republican
who's big on states rights right who
will get no traction really
or a democrat could say it too but they
would just say it's not federal
government's responsibility look
democrats would be it would behoove them
to do that so they could say look we're
not trying to be big government and
regulate you let the states decide and
kind of say look republicans if that's
what you like then you just like my
policy it'll be the candidate on the
ropes
right pull out the pop boy boom throw
that out to hey but i may have all these
scandals but look what i brought here i
got weed for everybody
we like that guy we don't know who he is
but we like him did you guys know that
texting is causing stress everyone
thinks that it's making your life easier
but it's actually killing you from the
inside that's right uh researchers at
washington and lee university have found
there's a correlation between texting
and stress levels and texting and
quality of sleep i actually have started
a thing where for a half hour before i
go to bed i'm off the phone believe it
or not i actually stopped tweeting for a
few minutes uh before i go to sleep uh
this doesn't surprise me that much
actually uh you uh researchers found
that people who send the most text
messages experience the most sleep
problems and a higher number of daily
texts was associated with more sleep
problems uh let's look at some more info
people who send a lot of text sleep
worse because they feel pressured to
reply to texts in the middle of the
night they sleep with the phone by their
bed so they're awoken by incoming texts
and people who communicate by text have
more stress in their friendships texts
are unable to convey the nuances
important in discussing sensitive issues
that that all seems uh pretty obvious to
me and i think we've all done that where
you you send a tweet or a text or
something right before bed and then
you're like oh did anyone respond or did
this person respond that and then it's
actually in your dreams it starts
burrowing its way into your brain how
much does this stuff uh affect you
i think it came to me
at a point later in my life where i
don't think about it when i sleep
i can still get kind of grumpy and farty
about some things to to pull me out of
it but there's times when i realize i am
reshaping the musculature of both my
hands yeah and now your people the thumb
as opposable has it is supposed to be
was never meant to do micro work like
this and people go and cameron diaz on
the set of bad teachers showed me a
trick for for texting thumb you take
your finger here and you take your hand
here you go
click and you push back like that and it
pops the bone back
feels like neck crack good in your hand
and uh
and also we could be invaded by aliens
right now when we'd have no idea because
no one looks up
they could be flying above us everyone's
in a conversation just not with the
people near them yeah how dangerous do
you think texting is really because
losing that nuance and losing just the
eye contact and and little things that
go on when you're talking to somebody
that we're becoming cold aren't we
through through texting i think it's
interesting that they
focused on texting on this and we're
talking about tweeting and we're talking
about facebook statuses they're just
talking about your interpersonal
communication with people who you
assumedly know right who you actually
know unlike exactly twitter right which
is the bio feedback loop you get if i
sent a tweet and oh my god do anyone
answer and if not i'm wanting to check
that tick to see um so i think with this
it's interesting is that
it's a chicken or egg situation were
these the same type of people that
before texting were the type of people
that had to have their boyfriend call
them in the middle of the night to let
them know they were home are these the
people that are already worried about
where their children are constantly are
these people going to be consistently
feel the need to be connected or need to
know what's going on with everyone in
their social circle anyway are these
just stress people that would be
stressing about what to have for
breakfast tomorrow what to wear it's
just replacement stress of am i getting
a text or not so
you know i think in this situation yeah
texting you can say that this makes you
more miserable and they may have
isolated to texting but i'd like to see
the other habits of these people or what
they did before texting existed that
probably kept them up at night anyway
yeah there's got to be some sort of
correlation between people that can't
sleep because of worry and anxiety and
people that are consistently texting but
the young kids i'd love to see the ages
on this because if it's kids that didn't
have anything before texting it'd be
interesting to see if this is a new
stress in their life right so it is part
of the problem here also that
yeah that you're willing to say things
on text that you wouldn't say to someone
in person you know what i mean because
you're losing all that nuance you're you
can be more direct that's why i have a
general thing like i only text really
for directions or i'm standing on this
corner come meet me or something you
know like i don't have the
conversational text i hate the content
the other way that once you put it in
writing someone has that forever if i'm
going to say some crazy to you you
better believe it's going to be in
person not through texting you know that
you know that's not recorded
i make trauma face time
and crazier things via text message i am
like what is wrong with you don't you
understand that's in writing somebody
could tweet out your text messages
people could put it on
threat to you i go you just put in
prints so everyone knows you're the
you're you're suspect one if anything
happens yeah and you don't oh you can
see them like delete no i copied the
page already right
this whole thing on facebook that was
pretty kind of gnarly he was hitting on
me and then when i didn't really
reciprocate it turned into this nasty
thing and i told some of his friends
about and they're like man he would
never do that in person and i was like
well then he's really stupid because i
just screen grabbed the whole entire
thing
in one second it could be everywhere i
didn't get bones there i didn't do it
because i was like gosh i don't want to
be involved in this um but i mean
wouldn't you say to me that doesn't make
any sense if you're going to say
something in person then then you'd be
crazy right so
there's a little of this that none of us
grew up on this we're not 14 and when i
was reading this article i kept thinking
of that scene in downton abbey where the
dowager county sees electricity for the
first time the light turns on and she
freaks out like this is a little bit of
that with us because we didn't grow up
on it so there's this inherent fear of
new things even though there's everyone
has new things when they grow up and it
usually doesn't destroy the generation
life just
keeps rolling on right those jalopies
are spooking the horses
people said television is ruining
society because everyone's parked in
front of the boob tube and you're on
your tv and now people are parked in
front of the youtube and they're you
know watching their computer and then
people are parked in front of their
phone and they're text messaging so
every generation has their elvis or has
their this thing is too wild for us or
too damaging for us um and then you know
who knows maybe lately you're playing
with your hologram is so dangerous
because you don't have any real friends
everything progresses to different
stages
yeah and not to totally blow your mind
folks but we are taping this at youtube
and you're watching on youtube
well that's nuts all right this is a
completely crazy story so burials in
japan have become so expensive on
average 27 000 which is like 2.2 million
yen or so they become so expensive that
people are launching their cremated
relatives into space which that part
actually sounds uh kind of cool to me
you can send your relatives ashes into
space elysium space incorporated which i
wonder if that came out before the movie
or not i think it did
they will uh send the cremated remains
of your uh mom or dad uh to circle the
earth for several months for only one
thousand nine hundred and ninety dollars
that's that's a deal uh and then you can
of course track where your relative is
because there's an app for that that's
right let's look at some of the facts
about the service about one gram of a
person's remains are placed into an
individual space grade aluminum capsule
missions will carry between 100 and 400
individual capsules and cost of renting
a burial plot as i said and a tombstone
in tokyo is about 2700
27 400
so 27 400
um
so we can all end up in space i guess
that's where we'll start on this rick
are you going to space when you leave
this mortal coil that's one of those
things that looks so great on paper
yeah and they're kind of i hope they've
factored in the ozone depletion because
if that's a space grade aluminum
cylinder
some of them might start making it in
and the irony is you know you're at the
funeral for your loved one and you get
hit by them as this flaming meteorite
slams in from you know upper atmosphere
yeah gives new meaning to a sign
that's right yeah yeah i love that
renting the space too
renting it you know or something like
that they got to evict them you know
yeah you got to kick them out when they
didn't make rent
i think that uh
it might be safer than living in japan
at this point there's some major
living the live people up out of there
too yeah you know um
i mean what do you think if they if it's
a cheaper alternative actually the idea
of having you some part of you go into
space when this thing's over actually
kind of appeals to me yeah what do you
think i mean for me it's one of those
things that's like frightening and cool
when i think about it just emotionally
i'm like oh my god that's so scary i
don't even want to know about this i'm
like wait that's really cool i want my
ashes shot in his face i mean where else
do i want to be you know right it's like
we're such nomads we're really you want
to be buried just be shot in the space
okay
but seriously i mean if you if it costs
30 000
to bury you
and this is safe to do
then
it seems like it's a decent alternative
i mean it sounds weird it sounds
freaking people probably going to
complain that something about it is
morally wrong or whatever but i want to
know what the scientists say i want to
know what people that actually study
space at nasa and everyone says and if
they're cool with it besides the fact
that we're going to have like space
garbage people floating around right so
that's the part so the psi
right so the sci-fi part of my brain
immediately what i thought was okay
we're going to send all this well
gravity of course but we're going to
send all these ashes of dead people up
there and then aliens are going to be
flying by and they're going to see the
ashes and they're going to think it's a
threat like look what we did to the last
guys
that's part two where you put some water
on it and then the whole other city
actually like mafia sign like
getting too close there aliens in space
what happens it just stays in orbit so
they orbit it a couple of times around
for a couple months and then
no no because it's in this it's in those
capsules they're going to send a whole
bunch of them up together and then i
think
no no i i know uh you track it you track
it and then like a meteorite the remains
disintegrate upon entering the earth's
atmosphere okay that's cool i'm into
that yeah
i've never been to tokyo
the apartments are like this small
people are like stacked almost on top of
each other it's incredibly expensive
it's incredibly busy and loud and
pollution is going up and it's you know
it's it's a nice city it's my favorite
city i've ever been to but you can tell
there's absolutely no space so i can't
even imagine a space murr
i can't i mean to me i'm like i have no
idea where they would put these people
and if they're gonna just disintegrate
after that that's kind of poetic and
cool i'm into this
as long as they disintegrate because
every time you launch a rocket you're
putting another little hole in the ozone
you keep launching rockets at the speed
they need to to get rid of all the
damage you have to be mass launching
them and others be cost effective can
you imagine every time someone's dead a
new rocket is like one per customer it's
going to be more of a limo rate than a
cab rate i'll tell you that
if it's one professor it's not going to
be 1990.
i can't the one customer i'm sorry you
got to sweep your card again yeah yeah
it's going to be a mass launch all right
people uh we did a lot here let's end
this shutdown let's legalize some weed
let's shoot dead people into space
that's jen hoffman that's rick overton
you can check them out on twitter it's
right beneath them right now and
subscribe that's also right down there
and uh i guess we'll do this again next
week
hey guys the reuben report is brought to
you by coupon.com they've got 75 percent
off dog and cat chews toys accessories
home goods and more use code rr for 20
off your next purchase the link is right
down there